let's talk about donald trump and what
he might do
now that he's lost the election the fox
news decision desk can now project
the 46th president of the united states
[Applause]
the big american news networks did the
math and called biden's win
the people of this nation have spoken
but trump is contesting
some results if you count the illegal
votes
they can try to steal
the election from us the results are
fake they're not
real so can trump still win in court
what can he do with the time he has left
in the white house and what if he
refuses to leave
no presidential candidate in the history
of the united states has
ever outright refused to concede richard
nixon bowed out even after accusing john
f kennedy and the democrats of rigging
votes
and once the decision is made we unite
behind the man
vice president al gore accepted the
supreme court's ruling that george w
bush won in florida
may god bless his stewardship of this
country
that was after a long legal battle and a
recount that came up with a razor thin
difference of 537 votes
but trump's not giving up and there are
things he can still do
in a tight race a candidate can request
a recount
georgia has already agreed to one but
recounts have only ever led to totals
that change by a few dozen votes
sometimes hundreds biden's lead in
battleground states is in the tens of
thousands
it's really hard to imagine a massive
shift in votes from biden that would
then
benefit donald trump a candidate can
also file a lawsuit if they suspect
irregularities
the trump campaign has challenged
electoral processes in several states
over things like republican observers
not getting close enough to the
accounting process
ballots that are otherwise valid being
counted after election date and
allegations of fraud
but lawsuits in michigan georgia
wisconsin
and arizona have already failed still
trump's lawyer rudy giuliani says
they're going to keep going
we've been deprived of the right to
inspect if a single one of those ballots
is legitimate
and i emphasize to you it's only one of
the many other
infirmities in this election there has
to be a pretty high bar of evidence
if you're going to accuse a state or a
locality of
widespread fraud which is what some
republicans and trump are doing
right now and there just isn't any
evidence of it
the election timetable means legal
battles can't go on forever
in most states recounts and court
challenges have to wrap up by december
8th
december 14 is when electors from each
state come together as the electoral
college to cast their votes
the presidential race has been called
for biden because enough democrat
electors are expected to confirm his
victory
the reports from those electoral college
meetings
then gets sent over to congress and then
congress counts the votes
on january 6th after all that trump can
make all the noise he wants but it won't
affect who takes the office of the
president
he doesn't even have to concede publicly
that's just
a usually respected tradition the
american people have spoken
i pray that the president will be
successful we must accept this result
and then look to the future whatever
happens it'll all be over
officially when trump's term ends at
noon on january 20th
2021 that's when the new president is
sworn in
hi john fitzgerald kennedy richard nixon
hi jimmy carter i'm george walker bush
barack hussein obama
do solemnly swear so what happens if
trump refuses to leave
donald trump at that point is a
trespasser at the white house
the white house is a very highly secure
place whether you're an employee or
whether you're the
former president of the united states
you can't just roll into the white house
without getting past secret service but
trump still has
10 weeks left in office and a lot can
happen in 10 weeks
he'll still be commander-in-chief and
can make important foreign policy
decisions
george bush senior for example sent
troops to somalia in his final weeks
and jimmy carter ended the iran hostage
crisis trump can also declassify
information and use the power of the
presidential pardon to free people from
prison or stop a trial if it's a federal
case
in terms of how he's going to act in the
next couple of months i think it's the
rhetoric that i think a lot of people
are very worried about
[Music]
especially at a time when it's a very
polarized country
the president had to know he was in
trouble when fox news his favorite tv
channel
called his defeat some of trump's allies
including the israeli prime minister
have already congratulated biden
none of that means trump can't put up a
fight it's his right
but it's probably not going to get him
very far
[Music]
the u.s election is far from over but
aljazeera.com has all the latest
in the meantime our team at start here
is working on more explainers
to help you understand what's going on
in the news we'll see you next week